Film criticism is definitely worthwhile, but
let’s be honest here: sometimes critics
get so caught up in whether or not a movie
is “good” that they stop considering whether
it’s fun to watch — and yes, there is
a difference.
From swashbuckling adventure to action-packed
sci-fi, here are some movies that the critics
despised, but are actually pretty awesome.
If you haven't seen them yet, beware of spoilers
ahead.
Hook
It seems like everybody hates Hook.
Film critics have savaged this 1991 Peter
Pan story as “embarrassingly excessive,”
“bloated,” and “a huge disappointment,”
and it’s widely considered to be Steven
Spielberg’s worst film.
But maybe that's because all those critics
have grown up and forgotten what it's like
to have an imagination.
Granted, Hook is nowhere close to being one
of Spielberg's best, but for a film about
childhood, it deals with some surprisingly
mature themes, like unrequited love and the
inevitability of death.
The story stars Robin Williams, playing Peter
Pan as an adult who changed his name, started
a family, became a lawyer, and totally forgot
about his adventures in Neverland until his
children were kidnapped by Captain Hook.
It's a film about dysfunctional families and
abandoned kids, and according to Evan Saathoff
of Birth.Movies.Death., Hook was a "very personal
movie for Spielberg, a reaction to his fears
that his heavy workload was robbing him of
time with his children."
In addition to the deep stuff going on behind
the surface, Hook is pure Spielberg-ian entertainment.
The sets—which are quite obviously sets—are
grand, ornate, and wonderfully larger-than-life,
which is fitting for a story that was first
a stage play.
Plus, you can't deny that Bob Hoskins, Maggie
Smith, and Dustin Hoffman are absolutely perfect
in their parts, and the score by John Williams
is pure magic.
Alien 3
When first-time director David Fincher was
hired for Alien 3, the movie was already behind
schedule.
There wasn't a finished script, and the studio
had lost several million dollars on the project.
Worse still, Fincher was severely hampered
by micro-managing producers at Fox, and when
the film clocked in around three hours long,
the studio forced him to cut about 30 minutes
of material.
As a result of that bad experience, Fincher
disavowed the 1992 film, but he wasn't the
only one who hated Alien 3.
Fans, and James Cameron, are still furious
about the deaths of Hicks and Newt, and most
critics panned the film, with many saying
it was style over substance.
It's true that Alien 3 puts a lot of emphasis
on atmosphere, but at the same time, that's
what makes it one of the most fascinating
movies of Fincher's storied career.
Set in a dreary wasteland that screams Mad
Max, this third installment is dark, grungy,
and beautifully barren cinematic nightmare.
Sigourney Weaver is at the top of her game
here, playing a more cynical Ripley who bravely
comes to terms with her inevitable fate.
True, the Xenomorph effects look a little
janky, and the forced edits take away from
the overall story, but despite the drawbacks,
Alien 3 is a visually brilliant world of criminal
monks and fiery hellscapes, a film that could've
been the perfect ending for a landmark series.
National Treasure
2004's National Treasure was described by
critics as "rancid cinematic cheese" with
“almost nothing to recommend it,” but
that's more than a little bit harsh.
The film follows Nicolas Cage as Benjamin
Franklin Gates, a historian who learns that
there's a treasure map hidden on the back
of the Declaration of Independence.
Unfortunately, fellow treasure hunter Ian
How, played by Sean Bean), decides to steal
the Declaration, forcing Ben and his sidekick
Riley to break into the National Archives
and get their hands on the document first.
With the Declaration in hand, Ben sets out
across the stomping grounds of America's Founding
Fathers, solving riddles and doing his best
to avoid a barrage of bullets.
It’s easy to argue that Cage was miscast
as the swashbuckling lead of a popcorn adventure
flick, and somebody definitely should've realized
there were 56 signers of the Declaration of
Independence, not 55, but National Treasure
really shines when our heroes are puzzling
over codes and trying to piece together clues.
There's invisible ink, hidden ciphers, and
glasses invented by Benjamin Franklin, not
to mention conspiracies involving the Masons
and the Knights Templar.
Plus, Sean Bean, Diane Kruger, and Harvey
Keitel are all fun to watch as they help and
hinder Cage in his quest to find the world's
biggest pile of gold.
RoboCop
Remaking a classic is always an uphill battle,
especially when that classic is a beloved
sci-fi masterpiece like RoboCop.
Jose Padilha's 21st century remake doesn't
stand a chance against Paul Verhoeven's 1987
original, but the 2014 version is definitely
a film with its own style and its own ideas.
Joel Kinnaman stars as Alex Murphy, a Detroit
cop who's been mortally wounded by a car bomb.
With his corpse mangled beyond recognition,
he's the perfect candidate for an experimental
program that turns him into a cybernetic super-cop.
Naturally, there's more going on with the
RoboCop program than meets the eye, and soon
enough, Murphy sets out to bring down the
big bads, dead or alive.
Admittedly, Kinnaman often has even less emotion
than Peter Weller, and the PG-13 rating means
that the original’s over-the-top violence
has been toned down considerably in the name
of making a buck.
Still, the 2014 film is surprisingly thoughtful,
focusing focusing on the widespread use—and
danger—of drone warfare and the increasing
militarization of urban police forces.
The satirical news sequences from the original
have been swapped out with Fox News-style
segments featuring an angry Samuel L. Jackson,
and there’s an interesting update to Alex
Murphy’s character arc.
In the 1987 film, Murphy starts off as a cold-blooded
cyborg who slowly regains his humanity.
But Padilha puts a nice twist on the story,
with an emotional Murphy becoming more and
more machine as the movie goes on, losing
his ability to connect with others.
The film also grapples with heady concepts
like free will, and while it lags in a few
places, it features an amazing in-the-dark
shoot-out and a truly horrific sequence where
Alex Murphy sees what's left of his body after
a near-fatal explosion.
It’s never going to replace the original,
but…
“I’d buy that for a dollar!”
The Last Boy Scout
Tony Scott’s The Last Boy Scout had an infamously
troubled production, thanks in part to the
enormous number of rewrites that screenwriter
Shane Black was forced to make.
As a result, we're left with a movie that's
messy, disjointed, and nowhere near as tight
as Black’s other work, like Lethal Weapon
or The Nice Guys.
That said, while it might be a little jumbled,
The Last Boy Scout is a fascinating slice
of action cinema, a movie full of insane little
moments involving car bombs, helicopter blades,
and foul-mouthed cat puppets.
It starts off with one of the most compelling
openings you'll ever see in an action movie,
with a drug-addled football player pulling
a pistol in the middle of a game.
From there, we're introduced to our heroes:
Cynical private investigator Joe Hallenbeck,
played by Bruce Willis, and has-been quarterback
Jimmy Dix, played by Damon Wayans, investigate
the brutal murder of Dix's girlfriend, a dancer
played by Halle Berry.
As the duo dig deeper into the case, they
uncover a plot involving gambling and the
NFL, but what's really important here is that
Shane Black's dialogue is still clever as
ever and the dynamic between Willis and Wayans
is crackling with frenemy energy.
“Leather pants?”
“Yeah.”
It has more than a bit of a problem when it
comes to its female characters, but on the
positive side, Taylor Negron shows up as one
of the very best Shane Black villains, and
we're treated to a scene in which Bruce Willis
murks a dude with the palm of his hand.
Anaconda
With a 38 percent approval rating on Rotten
Tomatoes, 1997's Anaconda is generally considered
pretty awful.
Critic Mick LaSalle slammed the film by saying,
"Anaconda is about a snake that eats everybody.
That about says it all."
Time Out London’s review added that the
snake doesn’t just eat people, it screams.
Steve Newton of The Georgia Straight also
piled on, writing,
"Just to show, early on, how much danger these
folks are in, we get to see the film's titular
star squeeze a black panther so tight that
one of its eyeballs pop out."
We’re not really seeing why this is a problem.
That’s exactly the kind of stuff that makes
Anaconda so amazing.
If you go into the movie expecting something
classy, you might walk away disappointed,
but if you're expecting the best B-movie ever,
then you'll have the time of your life.
It’s the kind of movie where a guy falling
from a waterfall gets snatched out of the
air by a snake hanging from a tree branch,
and where you can watch a guy get swallowed
alive from inside the anaconda itself.
In addition to the killer creatures, there's
Jon Voight as Paul Sarone, a madman who chews
up all the scenery in sight.
Every one of his lines is an over-the-top
gem, and he strangles somebody with his own
legs before dousing Jennifer Lopez with a
bucket of monkey blood.
What's not to love?
Snow White and the Huntsman
2012's Snow White and the Huntsman has been
accused of being “putrid and seemingly endless,”
“strange and soulless,” and “underwhelming,”
with a “woeful” script... but it's worth
watching for the visuals alone.
Directed by Rupert Sanders, this gritty fantasy
has images on par with something you might
see in a movie directed by Guillermo del Toro.
There's the battle where knights fight an
army of soldiers made of glass, or the scene
when Queen Ravenna bathes herself in a milky
brew, right after munching on a bird's heart.
A white stag bursts into a thousand butterflies,
and after turning into a flock of ravens,
Ravenna crawls from a pit of black ooze, surrounded
by the fluttering of dying birds.
With sequences like these, Snow White and
the Huntsman is equal parts dreamland and
nightmare fuel, and it doesn't hurt that Charlize
Theron throws herself into playing the world's
most evil witch, cranking up the volume and
turning on the terror every time she walks
on-screen.
While Theron is wonderfully nuts as Queen
Ravenna, Kristen Stewart, the most underrated
actress in Hollywood, anchors the film with
a much more realistic and empathetic performance
as Snow White.
Even Chris Hemsworth steps up his acting game,
and while it would've been preferable if they'd
used actual little people, the dwarfs are
played by some of the very best British character
actors, like Bob Hoskins, Nick Frost, and
Ian McShane, and they lighten things up every
time they appear.
Sure, it doesn't compare to the Walt Disney
classic, but then it's not really trying to.
This is a Snow White movie that's more about
the dark side of fairy tales—the blood,
the mud, the horror, and the wonder.
Clash of the Titans
With reviews like New York Magazine’s, which
said “It isn’t a train wreck—a train
wreck would be memorable,” 2010's Clash
of the Titans racked up a miserable 28% rating
on Rotten Tomatoes, and went down as a mistake
of mythological proportions.
Even the star, Sam Worthington said the movie
"let down some people."
But honestly, if the critics didn’t like
it, that might’ve been because they lost
their sense of fun.
Clash of the Titans is a good, old-fashioned
B-movie, a throwback to a time when Hollywood
made adventure flicks that could charm you
with crazy creatures, over-the-top set pieces,
and a whole lot of imagination.
The story itself is pretty simple.
Mankind is getting sick of the gods bossing
them around, so they decide it's time to rebel.
Naturally, the gods don't approve, so they
threaten to unleash the monstrous Kraken if
the human king doesn't sacrifice his daughter.
Desperate, the king turns to a demigod named
Perseus, asking him to find a way to kill
the beast.
Along the way, Perseus encounters a murderous
Medusa, some oversized scorpions, and a trio
of witches.
He zips in between towers on a Pegasus, teams
up with a group of desert-dwelling jinn, and
is forced to deal with all-powerful gods like
Liam Neeson's Zeus and Hades, play by Ralph
Fiennes, who turn the Shakespeare up to 11.
Mix that in with a bunch of monsters and magic,
and you can see how Clash of the Titans is
the exactly kind of movie that might inspire
the next George Lucas to make the next Star
Wars.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!